James tribe author of the new book on
wet tech entitled too good to be true
how is it that a small tool and die
company in South Bronx can quickly grow
to be a 100 million dollar a year
defense contractor sheer brazenness I
suppose in part wet tech seems to prove
that if you're completely shameless
about paying people off and using
political influence and cheating on the
books and doing all sorts of things you
can achieve anything it's also true
though that it was an one level and
extraordinarily idealistic and Noble
looking enterprise and that when a very
long way towards persuading people that
wet tech was something special
good evening we're very pleased to have
with us mr. James tribe the author of
too good to be true
the a blandish story of wet tech it's a
new book out on Doubleday and if you
have a question or comment for our
guests our telephone lines are open - OH
- six - eight - five - five if you're
watching us in the east - OH - seven
eight three - seven - seven if you're
watching us in the West and I'll tell
you this is going to be an interesting
discussion mr. Trott how long have you
been looking into the wet tech issue I
guess I spent about a year and a half or
so working on it it's an incredibly it
was a very complicated and varied story
with so many scandals all put together
at the same time so there was an awful
lot of material to cover it was a long
process your book of course details many
of the players both within wet tech and
here in Washington who were involved but
let's start I think one of my favorites
is mr. John Marriott oh why don't you
tell our viewers who john mariotta is
well John Marriott Oh was the chairman
and a founder of wet tech and despite
the fact that he's now languishing in
federal prison he's a person who you
can't help having a certain amount of
grudging admiration for him he always
referred to himself as a New York Rican
which was the phrase he used to refer to
somebody who really had not himself been
born in Puerto Rico but was a Puerto
Rican background and he also said of
himself and truly that he came from a
kind of Twilight Zone linguistically he
didn't speak English well and he didn't
speak Spanish well and he was
essentially semi illiterate at a lot of
trouble reading
very valuable personality impetuous
ferocious ill-tempered generous and this
really very unlikely personality turned
this tiny little company which began as
a tool-and-die firm in the South Bronx
into a hundred million dollar company
and and charmed President Reagan and
many others as well we have a picture
here from your book of mr. Mariana
talking with Fred Neuberger who was his
partner can you tell us a little bit
about mr. Neuberger yes the way I'd also
like to say beforehand that one of the
reasons I like this picture is that this
is the this is the pre corporate
makeover picture you'll see you see the
book that later on the two of them when
they get older and wealthier are seen
wearing business it wasn't looking
splendid Fred Neuberger also an unusual
character was born in Romania
essentially was a holocaust escapee
tells an amazing story of having walked
across Central Europe and then across
Asia with other children in order to
escape the Nazi Menace came to Israel
was a terrorist something he was very
proud of talked about killing people
became a very hard-bitten
sort of pitiless fellow came to United
States and eventually in 1970 joined up
with John mariotta and the two of them
had a sort of combustible relationship
which consisted often of throwing things
and hurling epithets at one another they
were they were infamous for their fights
now one of the things you detail in the
book is of course the transformation of
wet tech into a so-called eight a firm
tell us a little bit about the 8a
program and why it became so important
to wet tech in a program was a very well
intentioned program designed to help MIT
already businessmen it was always
popular with even Republican
administrations because essentially it
helped middle-class blacks and
middle-class Hispanics now if we had a
certain amount of political value what
it did was that it set aside contracts
federal government contracts for
companies that were owned and operated
by minority members Nixon had
essentially started that as part of his
drive to create what he called black
capitalists and a voting bloc among
blacks the Reagan administration saw it
as a tremendous opportunity to promote
the interests of Hispanics because the
Reagan political operatives had come to
feel and perhaps rightly that his
were more conservative in certain ways
and were a likely block for for
Republicans so what happened over the
years was that this this program became
a kind of a kind of corporate welfare
program for companies that instead of
being in there for a few years to get
contracts get up in their feet and go
away
we'd stay in there forever and would
establish essentially a sort of
dependency on this program wet tech was
the great example of a day dependency it
received tens of millions of dollars of
contracts in this program and never
achieve the kind of self-sufficiency
that was the goal and essentially what
it did was that it learned to manipulate
the bureaucrats in the program and the
program itself with consumer skill some
of the some of the contracts they got of
course were defense contracts that
catapulted them into the 100 million
dollar a year range but can you tell us
the kinds of things they did before and
after they entered the 8a program before
they entered the 8a program they were a
teeny tiny little tool and dye firm in
the South Bronx that actually originally
they made parts for baby carriages that
was their history it was only in 1975
when they joined this program that they
started making essentially military
equipment once they got onto the program
they made very substantial things and I
like to emphasize that people tend to
think that wet tech was a kind of
Potemkin company that didn't really do
anything whereas in fact they actually
did turn out engines and I wouldn't be
at all surprised if generators out in
the middle of the desert in Saudi Arabia
right now had engines and that were
built in web tech by wet tech they they
essentially had two big contracts they
won both through political influence one
a contract to build engines for the army
27 million dollar contract they got in
1982 and then two years later through
really just ingenious and complex
political maneuverings they won a
contract from the Navy over the
objections of all of the uniformed
officers to build what we call pontoon
cosway's which essentially are
mechanisms for transferring material
from shore to ships and shallow water
ports and that was their great
contract and in the end it was their
great boondoggle because they couldn't
handle the difficulty and that in itself
is a great story I want to go back to a
photo that we showed just a moment ago
of the of a very important day in the
life of wet tech and particularly John
maryada the here he is well why don't
you tell us what's going on in this
picture I don't know whether people can
see clearly enough the the the wondrous
thing about this picture is that on the
far left it kind of point from left we
have John Mary Otto who is the chairman
of wet tech then we have various
important personages including then Vice
President Bush and a number of mayors
there's Donald Regan over there a former
congressman barber Conable and verily
far right looking roughly at this
gentleman is of course President Reagan
and what had happened there was that
mariotta had been invited in January of
1982 to speak or of not really to speak
simply to attend a kind of symposium for
what was called the urban Enterprise
Zone which is a piece of legislation the
administration was was pushing and he
was frankly terrified of the whole thing
he had never been in a setting like that
in his life in walk President Reagan and
maryada began speaking and he delivered
a very strange monologue and of the
people I've spoken to who were there
most of them said they thought this
fellow was very well-meaning but just
strange it was so disjointed and his
manner of speaking was so high-pitched
and ferocious and out of control well
President Reagan was delighted this man
essentially was preaching the virtues of
free enterprise he was talking about the
opium of welfare and so on he delivered
a Whitney that the president loved and
that I think may have had some effect on
webtext political fortunes at the very
least made Marriott and wet tech feel
that they had been blessed by the Reagan
administration there's so many stories
in your book I wish we had time to go
through them but I think it's important
that our viewers get a sense of some of
the key players first of all why don't
you talk about the introduction and role
of the key members of Congress who
became involved with when - well there
are three or four and some of them came
calling by themselves and some of them
wet tech found Mario Biaggi to form a
congressman from the Bronx who was later
indicted and convicted for Israel
the way Tech's candle suddenly showed up
at the company's door in 1978 he had he
I think his view of politics was the
old-fashioned view that it's a vehicle
for for self-aggrandizement and here was
a company parked actually adjacent to
his constituency it wasn't in his own
territory and he showed up one day and
essentially said you folks in need a
lawyer he had a law firm at the time and
that was not in itself illegal well the
white tech boys weren't stupid they saw
that there was some sort of quid pro quo
being offered here that they would pay
beyond you retainer and he would help
them politically and so he did and he
helped got well no the help didn't get
that much of large of the payment got
larger he eventually demanded extorted
two and a half million dollars with a
stop from wet tech he was he was one
another was the congressman from the
adjacent district Robert Garcia
he too was indicted and convicted for
extorting money from wet tech though his
conviction was overturned an appeal he
had a much more clever method he had his
wife say that she wished to serve as a
consultant to Wed tag for $4,000 a month
and wet tech said we don't really need a
consultant but it was understood that
need had nothing to do with it and again
it must be said that he only did just so
much for the company these fellows I
think in part operated out of out of
instilling fear and these well they
really are the primary ones there are
other congressmen including senator
D'Amato who receive large amounts of
campaign contributions from Wayne tech
not illegal of course a common
occurrence who in turn went to
tremendously great lengths to intervene
in the political process or the
government process to get contracts for
the company and of course there are the
people who were the so-called
go-betweens between wet tech and the
government who are some of the key ones
the most important person and a
genuinely strange individual among the
strange wet tech folks was a fella named
Robert Wallach he Robert walk was ed
Meese his best friend had been for years
they were very very close a lawyer from
San Francisco sort of a pious fellow
really thought of himself and very very
moral terms and a person who had done a
lot of good in his life became very
attracted to this company and I think at
first tried to help but out of the
goodness of his heart and later came to
see it as an economic
opportunity and he began pelting his
friend ed meese then the counselor to
President Reagan and perhaps the
president's closest political friend
with memos about this company and this
process went on for years there are
hundreds of memos very few of which I
suspect nice-nice ever read but they
made enough of a difference that along
with other people including when nob
cigar the another former operative for
President Reagan they succeeded in
getting influence in the White House and
helping wet tech get contracts you have
in the years that you've been writing
for magazines you have done a lot of
writing about criminal conduct and
particularly criminal enterprises what
is it that makes this story so special
how is this different from any other
fraud or crooked you know lead in and of
itself is not that interesting a motive
for doing things
it's an appetite and I think had wet
tech just been a story about a group of
con men who set out to defraud the
government and then did so I I don't
think I would have written a book about
it what is what is interesting to me is
the strange mixture of an almost
crusading mentality which began with his
fellow John mariotta and worked its way
down throughout the company the company
employed previously unemployable people
from the ghetto all black and Hispanic a
sense of this great noble venture which
began with Marriott and went through the
rest of the people in the company
including his fellow Robert Wallach
which mixed with the fact that the
company more and more became an ongoing
criminal enterprise and one reason the
company was so successful in getting
other people to help it is that there
was always this quality which was
partially a mask and was partially real
of idealism and one of the things I came
to realize in writing about this is that
there is nothing like a good cause to
let people do things they want to do for
themselves it's a wonderful opportunity
a kind of moral opportunity which
everybody in the end availed themselves
of James Traub is our guest the author
of too good to be true the outlandish
story of wet tech as it is subtitled if
you have a question or comment our lines
are open we're talking about of course
the same
or infamous wet tech scandal let's start
with our first caller in Miami Florida
nice to hear from you go ahead all right
I have a couple questions
well I'll point in a question first of
all how do you think this impacts our
economy with just really a small small
slice of the picture white egg there's
all kinds of companies getting their
hands into the deep pockets of the
taxpayer how deep is it Ron I mean the
roosters eventually come home to roost
well I think the answer in specific case
of wet deck is is very small that is the
amount of money that the company
probably squandered was maybe two or
three hundred million dollars the the
larger I think part of your question
though is how significant is the amount
of squandering that goes on through
political influence like web tech and I
think in that case you can see a
parallel between wet tech and for
example the SNL crisis where once again
through the use of political influence
and political contributions partially
corrupt partially not people who are
self-interested were able to sway the
government in order to bend the rules or
break the rules on their behalf and in
in that case the economic effect was
enormous the fact is those rules are
there for a good reason and in many
cases have grown up over a long period
of time and I think once they begin to
be circumvented there's no bottom to it
Silver Spring Maryland nice to hear from
you go ahead hi I just like to ask for
your comment on whether the prosecution
of wet tech executives might have fallen
by the wayside in light of the large
political figures that were at stake and
and shouldn't the prosecution really
have exactly a higher toll from the
people who are responsible for the
crimes rather than the people who were
tempted to compromise their political
responsibilities I think there are two
parts to that question part one I
suspect is probably a question about
people like ed Meese that is it's it's I
think widely thought that since wet tech
had these very powerful friends who must
have been doing something corrupt in
their behalf why is it that for example
ed Meese went free well the fact is that
the
the special prosecutor which is
appointed to look into Meis was staffed
by a lot of people who were very eager
to find that nice in his helping of wet
tech had engaged in some sort of quid
pro quo which was illegal they didn't
like him particularly and there was a
lot of smoke they were looking for fire
there wasn't any and I suspect that at
least in Mises case he there was no
expectation of money and there was no
over crime I think there was a
tremendous dereliction of his
responsibility and I find is his
nonchalant behavior in behalf of wet
tech almost incredible but I don't think
there was any crime there and I don't
think that higher-ups went unpunished
the other part of the question is
whether the people who committed the
crimes got off too lightly and I think
that may be true the people who were at
the centre of the company cooperated
with the government they spent awful lot
of time helping the government in the
end they served a year a year and a half
two years in jail and the only moral of
that story is if you do something
terrible
make sure you cooperate with the
government afterwards and give them the
names of some famous and important and
powerful people so as to make them feel
you've given them something important
Houston Texas thanks for waiting go
ahead yes please this call this question
is directly to the moderator and I'd
like you to answer this question I like
I find it absolutely repugnant I find it
to be an abomination that you invited
dr. post to speak about to speak about
who said Saddam Hussein since is a
professional psychiatrist and he came in
there speaking biased with a biased
opinion about a man I like I like you to
invite me to their programs that I can
respond in a non certain times what I
will tell you viewer that I do not do
the inviting around here but we
certainly would welcome your letter if
you would like to appear and anyone else
who is concerned about a viewpoint as
those of you who are regular c-span
viewers no we attempt to bring people
from all different viewpoints and that
is one viewpoint on Saddam Hussein and
if you've been watching c-span you know
that we've had many many people on
discussing the Middle East with very
different views so please feel free to
write us and we would certainly look
into that thank you
for the common let me go back to this
wet tech scandal for just a moment one
of the people that you talk about in the
book is former congressman parren
Mitchell who was known around Washington
as being something of a champion of
issues involving minority business tell
me the story of his involvement and
particularly that of the Mitchell
brothers as well it's an interesting
story and I think in the congressman's
part a little perplexing and not
completely solved to my satisfaction
story is essentially this that finally
people started catching up with wet tech
and in late 1984 the Small Business
Committee in Congress which parren
Mitchell chaired had received
information that wet tech was
manipulating its its White House
contacts to unfairly get big contracts
so they started to look into it well
what happened was wet tech of course
just freaked out and they thought we've
got to do something to quash this
investigation now they had friends in
the SBA and they tried to use them they
had congressmen there were other
Hispanic businessmen they did everything
they could to quash the investigation
not really working too well then through
a series of very complicated contacts
they came upon two brothers Clarence and
Michael Mitchell who were lawyers in
Baltimore one of them was a state
legislator they were cousins of parren
Mitchell and apart me they were nephews
of Baron Mitchell and they said we can
get to parren Mitchell we can make him
stop the investigation and so with the
kind of hugger-mugger that was typical
of wet tech it was a meeting at a bar
and so on and $50,000 in cash soon
changed hands later on the investigation
was stopped the wet tech folks always
assumed that the Mitchell brothers had
said whatever it is one says in these
situations impaired and Mitchell had
said fine and in fact government
investigators assumed the same thing and
at first he was a prime suspect the fact
is there is no evidence these fellows
actually did anything exactly why the
investigation was stopped is is a
different issue
I don't think though the parent Mitchell
really engaged in any kind of corrupt or
remotely corrupt activity Los Angeles
California thanks for waiting go right
ahead oh thank you
I have a small distribution
company of aerospace after milspec part
in the los angeles area and had some
dealings with wed tech about nineteen
eighty-four of the early part of the
year one of the things that I
experienced with that company was after
accepting a quotation from my company
and giving a verbal purchase order over
telephone and accepting the parts after
they were shipped to them they would
consistently send confirming purchase
orders with different prices in other
words they were actually getting the
parts for cheaper than what we were
buying them for based on the confirming
orders and I never could quite get
renumeration for the part I wondered if
this was a very consistent tactic of wet
tech and I'm sure it figures into the
overall picture well I must say the
first thing that your question inspires
me to say is that reporters only get to
meet useful sources after it's too late
I wish I had known you beforehand the
answer is that wet Tech's stiffed an
awful lot of people and especially when
when money went dry which he did on a
regular basis I think they had
constantly difficult relationships with
their suppliers and by the end were
scarcely paying them at all and they'd
wait until they raised some money in a
public offering they paid them off and
then they basically not pay them again
for the longest time they were tough to
deal with but you do talk in your book
about invoices that suddenly show up
with whiteout on them and yes they think
one of their clever schemes that what
happened was a lot of the crime wet tech
engaged in was not planned out what
happened is they they were badly one
company in part because of their own
ambition so they were always desperately
scrambling to stay alive
they were always running out of money
they were always on the edge of
bankruptcy the first time has happened
was in 1980 and they really thought were
going bust this is it and then one of
the fellows in the accounting department
mentioned
that he had submitted some inadvertently
he said some invoices to the Defense
Department for work that had not in fact
yet been done and they had been
reimbursed well it dawned on people
higher up that this might be a fine new
method for staying alive and after I
think some fairly tortured discussion
because it was the first over of fraud
they'd really committed I was a snowy
day it was all who knows what what
difficult psychology was involved they
said fine let's go ahead and then for
the next several years they engaged in
this phony invoicing scheme is this
known as near-death experience one
I think that's near-death experience one
actually I think there's seven total in
the book there's a marvelous titles in
the book let's go back to the phones
Minneapolis thanks for waiting go ahead
interrupt you and have you lower the
volume on your television as quickly as
you can we're getting a great deal of
feedback I'm wondering if in your book
you're mentioning about the downfall of
the James Baker ministry and how webpack
figured into some of their financial
dealings and whether it had anything to
do with the payoff to Jessica Hahn I
must say I love these kinds of questions
because there's a certain aspect of wet
tech that they were sort of connected to
everything and what you've asked I think
refers to about a complicated series of
transactions but essentially what
happened was that the sister of
congressman Robert Garcia had a church a
Pentecostal church in the Bronx and she
had some affiliation with Jim Baker's
Empire and it was stated at Jim Baker's
trial that money from Baker had been
laundered through this woman whose name
was Amy
Garcia core tazing to Jessica Hahn both
a $2,000 payment and a ten thousand
dollar payment wonderfully her church
was called the crossroads Tabernacle
Church because she became in a way these
sort of crossroads between this one
scandal and another otherwise completely
unconnected scandal Waterbury
Connecticut nice to hear from you go
ahead okay
together on your in your book about its
back offerings yes there are what is it
you'd like to ask about I just wondered
if you looked into it whether there was
anything fraudulent yeah as a matter of
fact the stock offerings are completely
fraudulent and there's a lot of civil
action right now in connection with them
because you know when you offer stock to
the public you're obliged to explain to
great lengths what the company's
finances are and what wet tech did in
its offerings both stock offerings and
later bond offerings it had two stock
offerings and two bond two offerings was
that it covered up a lot of the the
worst problems financially at one point
really I think the sort of high point of
this particular form of fraud it claimed
to have received from the Navy a thirty
million dollar contract which the Navy I
think had barely even contemplated
giving it and the amazing thing about
all this false information which was
presumably being read by very
sophisticated investors is that nobody
ever said a word I think that there's
something about the veracity of a finely
printed business document that people
just take it for granted that it must be
true because it's there and so nobody
ever detected those falsehoods until it
was too late very briefly can you tell
us what the role of Lynn Knopf singer
was yes I should explain that Linda knop
cigar like a Denise was a longtime
friend and associate of the President
had been with him President Reagan that
is had been with him since 1965 in early
82 after spending a year as the head of
what was called the office of political
affairs the obstacle quit in the in the
time-honored fashion to become a
lobbyist or a consultant or he had some
other name like publicist he took as one
of his clients wet tech one of the first
things he did was write a letter to his
old friend and former colleague ed Meese
saying these guys are looking for a big
engine contract they deserve it it's a
great political opportunity for us to
give him the contract let's not blow it
and for having written that letter he
was indicted for violating the Ethics in
Government Act he was convicted and a
conviction was later overturned on
appeal how much money do you make from
wet tech you know I've had trouble
determining it
I think that over the years he may have
gotten as much as three to four hundred
thousand dollars maybe a little bit less
it was a significant piece that you're
writing that letter no but he actually
got money like that for writing letters
some other companies wet tech couldn't
pay him quite the big bucks that some
other people did Middletown Connecticut
go right ahead with your question
accounting
yeah good evening very interesting what
is the problem what is the percentage of
politicians involved with companies like
what tech or influenced by them or
vice-versa how widespread is this
problem well obviously I don't know what
the there is any such thing as a
percentage but again the SNL crisis is
sort of instructive here because the
more that we've come to know about the
SNL's the more we've seen that these
people who at a local level are very
important politically to two candidates
in two congressmen find ways of
establishing a kind of subtle unspoken
quid pro quo I will help you and then
when I need you you'll go to bat in the
case of the SNL's it's obviously it's
extremely widespread and what else is
going on in this world one doesn't know
but I think what we do know is that this
has become accepted means of behavior
and it's really unavoidable for
politicians who have to raise immense
quantities of money given the way the
electoral system works Belmont
Massachusetts nice to hear from you
what's your question are common
white-collar crime been banned at this
station in fact c-span because they tend
to talk about white-collar crime paola
cash bribes in the media and because
that Brian lamb doesn't allow me on this
show at all in fact I'm sorry you're
about to get bleeped again you are a
violator of our 30-day policy and we'd
like you to wait at least 30 days before
you call back again too good to be true
you have written a number of articles
about wet tech why is it that this is so
particularly fascinating is it a story
about the Reagan administration is it a
story about the SBA 8a program
where do you see the main story well for
me personally it's several different
things one is that it's just a kind of
incredible narrative
I'm fascinated in the people I'm
fascinated in the complexity of people's
motives to me it's like a piece of found
literature at the same time on the level
of politics it's very interesting to me
I would say in terms of the atmosphere
that surrounds the whole thing the sense
that wherever these people went in
politics in a small business
administration among lawyers among
bankers everywhere there was always a
way of saying yes to what they wanted
and as a kind of moral adventurer or a
moral misadventure
I find it instructive and and fairly
appalling Eugene Oregon go ahead with
your question or comment yeah that seems
like this is a situation that is much
wider spread and you may realize I did
some research in terms of economic
patterns and the military spending in
the early 80s and I found it it was
almost directly proportional to
political influence like 30 percent of
the military buildup going to President
Reagan's home state huge economic booms
driven by military spending and the
speaker the houses home state of
Massachusetts and defense expert Sam
Nunn Georgia and likewise among other
states you know Bob Dole state getting a
huge increase left Aspen state getting a
huge percentage increase so it seems
like that almost the entire military
budget or or the vast majority of it is
driven heavily by political influence
and not by better choices do you think
that could be true oh I think it is true
beyond a doubt there is a theory and I
think it's more than a theory it's
almost a proven fact that that the
government pardon me the defense
contracting has worked over the years in
such a way that no major defense
contractor was allowed to go out of
business that is the system is so
politicized because of the immense
importance of the big contractors that
they are always assured of getting a
contract when they need it which prom
explains why so few major defense
contractors have gone out of business
the other part of your question is how
these fellows use their political power
and I think what the web tech people saw
and they looked around them was that
that was the norm that's what everybody
did if you were really important and
sophisticated you've had a hunting lodge
in the Eastern Shore of Maryland or you
had a yacht you had something like that
and you entertain politicians and they
helped you when the time came these
fellows just said well what can we do to
get a piece of that same pie what's our
form of behavior our guest James trav
specializes in writing about crime
issues and the criminal justice system
is reported on wet tech for the New
Republic and also the New York Times
Sunday magazine his new book is entitled
too good to be true the outlandish story
of wet tech that's out in Doubleday and
it's in the bookstores now I sure hope
so
Tarpon Springs Florida thanks for
standing by go right ahead yes hello go
ahead oh yes I live in Tarpon Springs
Florida right now but I formerly lived
in New York and my question is they
scandal on the wood tech situation and
then some of the other scandals in New
York manners and so many other
situations that came up over this
several years that I was there do you
think because of the control of the
Democratic Party on the system in New
York say it's a one-party system so that
they get entrenched yeah Mario Biaggi
was a Democratic congressman from the
Bronx
the Ghazi is etc that a better two-party
system in New York would have at least
prevented some of these candles yes I
think the fact is that there are certain
similarities traditionally between the
way New York politics have operated and
let's say the Politburo and there I
think what you've identified is that
sense of impurity that comes from
knowing you can never be turned out of
office and yes I think that it really is
a consequence Atlanta Georgia go ahead
two questions first where was Congress
that when this 8a program was being the
money was being distributed me it sound
like they fell asleep it's glitch and
watching won't happen in two if you
write another book do you think you can
write one on the candle within Congress
right now with the babies alone practice
I'll hang up thank you thanks I wasn't
the the what was the scandal I couldn't
hear the Savings and Loan scandal ah yes
well I tell you about the the book
question about the Savings and Loan
scandal was first there I think already
at least two fairly worthy books in the
Savings and Loan scandal that came out a
year or two ago and second if there were
less than half a dozen of my colleagues
out there writing proposals for books on
that subject right now I'd be surprised
so I think I'll probably leave that to
somebody else there's other questions
where was Congress when it came to their
oversight responsibilities of the 8a
program well that goes back to the
parent Mitchell question and if I can
just expand on that a little bit what
finally happened was in late 84 it came
to their attention that there was this
problem and they faced a real difficulty
they realized that wet tech might be a
serious now a family they might have
done something really wrong now the one
place where I suspect Mitchell probably
can be faulted as he did not at that
point aggressive we say let's hold
hearings let's investigate them it's a
perfect instance of what's wrong with
this program instead he kicked it back
to the the Small Business Administration
which of course was involved with
helping wet tech and there the
investigation was muffled and muted and
very safely smuggled out of sight
Westchester Pennsylvania go right ahead
I I was indirectly involved with wet
tech at one time and did some analysis
of their financial statements and I'm
wearing up mr. trop could comment on the
their stock at one time was one of the
hottest stocks being pushed by brokerage
firms in the New York market and someone
made a tremendous amount of money on
their stock that's one question I was
just wondering in and what finally
happened with the company after after
all this was finalized well you're
certainly right about people making a
lot of money on the stock and of course
brokers are paid in part in relation to
the amount of stock that they're able to
move and I think that the people who
originally broker did
we're Tech's initial public offering
probably did quite well with themselves
I've only met one person who said
there's something wrong with this
company or so he said he thought at the
time and he refused to be a part of it
everybody did want to be a part of it
what happened was that the company went
bankrupt in December of 86 everybody who
held wet tech stock or wet tech bonds
lost all of it and there are a lot of
individuals and a lot of banks and
insurance companies and others who were
out a heck of a lot of money because of
wet tech Oakland California nice to hear
from you go ahead yes good afternoon I
have been doing quite a bit of writing
in the same area I write for several
national magazines it is interesting
that you have done so much work on this
wet tech it's been around a long time I
believe that the eight a we were looking
at how this thing got underway is the 8a
program itself making an easy access to
all government agency we're talking 60
government agencies DoD's being the
largest
now since the 8a program inception I
guess about 1961 the change to minority
business enterprise takes over about 75
78 we're now looking at in fiscal year
89 I guess about three billion dollars
passing through the 8a program to a very
small percentage of contractors no more
than 1,200 just from DoD alone now in
the fiscal year 90 that will increase to
somewhere between 12 to 15 billion
dollars and there are only 3400
contractors on the program and for them
to reach the 15 billion dollar mark it
would take 60 years on an annual basis
do you think that this could cause even
more of where Tech's in the future
because the race and the amount of money
is there the accessibility is there the
amount of sharp sharp contractors that
are right now I'm doing 20 million up to
60 70 80 million dollars a year right
now do you believe that crime could
increase and significantly we're talking
about the OD Department of Energy and
as the top three don't get is in terms
of eighty satisfied well I don't know
anything about the numbers that you've
mentioned certainly if true I think
you're absolutely right because this is
a system which is does a very poor job
it's self governance so if you offer all
this money to people and it's so easy to
obtain it by political influence and and
the question of merit is so unclear I
think you're asking for corruption and
the fact is the program has been so
politically useful in order to prove an
interest in the welfare of minorities by
politicians that nobody has ever really
wanted to thoroughly discipline it and
it's been reformed again and again
without really doing very much good
there's an interesting story in the
beginning of your book that I think
speaks to that point that I'd like you
to quickly share it talks about the fact
that wet tech was initially owned 5050
and in order for a firm to qualify for
the 88 program its supposed to be at
least 51% minority-owned what happened
here well I think I should say first
that this is one of wet Tech's most
modest frauds what happened was that
when the the the to the fellow Fred
Neuberger joined the company in 1970 he
and John Mary out of the founder would
split the company 50/50 when they
applied for the SD set-aside program in
1975 they decided that wouldn't look
good so they made it 66 33 and nobody
was the wiser they they changed the
stock books and so on
then a third person joined and then it
became the real ownership became 45459
but again they altered the book so one
of their various running frauds and I
say it's not so grave only in the sense
that other companies in the program were
far more Larson isn't dishonest about it
was this concealment of the actual
ownership of the company Reading
Pennsylvania go right ahead
I own a clothing manufacturing company
here in the city now we what it is is a
cutting service we do cutting of cloth
for various companies who manufacture
now
if I get a tip that this company's stock
is going to go through the roof over a
certain item that's it's new and I
decide well you know I wouldn't mind
having some stock in that company and I
go and buy stock and I company from a
tip I got from someone inside the
company who knows what's going on how
does that differ from stock brokers who
are in the business to make money who
get tips on certain stocks or certain
companies when they go ahead and they
they if they would buy stock in that
company or through knowledge from a
person that is directly involved with
the purchasing all right all right I
don't want to cut you off I think we've
got the gist of your question well first
I should say I really don't know that
much about the insider trading laws and
I think that's what you're referring to
I think the question is there there is
an issue as to exactly who is considered
an insider at a corporation and if you
receive the information from someone who
is legally considered an insider then
both you and he are at least in theory
liable for violating the insider traders
trading statutes Chester Maryland you
are the last caller go right ahead
Chester are you there please be quick
we're running out of time okay I guess
my main interest is I know you're an
author but it would be nice if somebody
could be involved with items like this
or processes of government in their
interactions to bring to the public's
eye when it is happening not after the
fact
all right caller I'm afraid we're out of
time very quickly a final word from you
mr. Trump well of course the reason I
write books like this is
to bring these things to the public eye
that's my means of doing it and I hope
that well if everybody reads the book
and maybe I'll have done some service
and that is the last word I'm afraid we
are out of time
James Straub has been our guest too good
to be true is the name of the book
the Outlander story of wet tech thanks
very much for joining us and stay tuned
for our next discussion